in the same time of the people where
martyrdom received me the premium of the
People's Republic Jo and I made some new
year affirmations of his own to my
questions in English the pillar gave
direct replies in Chinese so I got oh ha
6 a high five ha
potato oh hey Lincoln mm sorry 1 ranking
Oh Shi
so after Jo I find such a sharp contrast
for the better
between conditions in China today and
those conditions I saw here in 1960 I
wonder if I would be right in assuming
that China's economic level general
economic level is now the highest in her
history so Tillich we saw Omega
commenting kitchen hall so tell me ho
Donna Jessica cousin boom - I ain't even
want to know that ever no way to tie
down huh yes it can now be dead our
national economy has achieved an
all-round firm the better just look at
the work of readjustment about it in the
main been completed he had work or to
output this year no surpassed the peach
figure at the end of the first five-year
plan and the house put of grains and
cotton in particular increased
considerably as compared with last year
on the industry industry
great progress has been made only in the
year
but also in the variety and quality of
the product and it can be said for them
all rounds leap forward has been made in
industry came in the years in science
and technology the kosher Jesus has been
really had a remarkable level she got
you can see what I'd be achieved in
culture and education from Gladys it
crumble reforms in the drama and the
development education Oh over Joey
Rohmer uniquely tuned as for market
supply you take that you have seen that
they did missus piece our plentiful
constant change it is true there still
is a city in the supply of cotton cloth
but the growth of cotton production from
over the past two years chosen will
provide a great possibility momentary
the way I'm eating the output of course
at the same time the production of
chemical fibers it's also increasing and
as a Coonan we are confident that in the
course from the third five-year plan
supply of coating for the people for
further Gras Tongo design ends you are
an in charge of situation you know
national economy in a fair and this one
of an all-round term for the better
culture and of an all-round growth this
will be conducive to an absurd you know
industrial agricultural production next
year and has also laid a good basis for
the third five-year plan you will soon
be having session of the National
People's Congress and after zoomit
you'll be making
port on all these matters I wonder if
you could give me some indication of the
main points didn't die as the jiggler
RTO hell
whose Congress come yang and December
21st it will be the first session of the
fairs National People's Congress on
behalf of the government I shall make a
report to the National People's Congress
on the work of the government but well
probably touched upon the following
three aspects first socialist confession
second socialist revolution and third
international questions do you see any
possibility of improvement Insano
American relations era
secondly do you think it would be useful
under present circumstances to have some
exchange of scientists and scholars too
when they open it and hang go down so
low and if it's only by the courage in a
beef you tone re-enters a change agent
to professor in order to improve
sino-american relations you know that we
must start with matters of principle and
not with side issues at the
sino-american ambassadorial talks in
warsaw we always put forward the
following two points of crystal one is
that agreement should be reached between
China and the United States on peaceful
coexistence on the faces of the five
principles and the other that the United
States must withdraw all its armed
forces from Taiwan and the Taiwan Strait
once the Primera can be reached on these
two points of principled our other
questions of it set off rather easily
for the stages will guarantee
otherwise you in the mirror pack line of
sight issues will not solve the
fundamental problem the Warsaw talks
have already been going on for more than
nine years for the United States all
along refused to agree on these two
points of principle the United States
follows others you think that it too is
for peaceful coexistence
but when China cause for it the United
States diffuses thurston disprove the
hypocrisy of the words of the US
government as for the question of visits
to China by some individuals no
agreement is possible at the present
time either those whom we welcome the US
government won't allow to come while
those it wants to central China are not
welcome violence we are generally put a
year work when issues of principle not
settle you sit in the US there's
deadlock email minor issues perhaps
you're an exception we welcome you and
the US State Department recently
permitted you to come under these
circumstances the indication that the
United States policy favors creation of
an independent Taiwan would seem to
remove the possibility perhaps for many
years out any normalization of sin
American relation well Pradesh in India
when you are my age is a pagoda yellow
ginger diner at the present time Chiang
kai-shek pecan pie want claims who
represent China of course nope patriotic
honey can't read that but yes there
should be someone on Taiwan who is so
depraved as to completely follow the
beck and call of the United States
and serve the needs of US policy by
declaring Iowa to be a so-called
independent political unit and relying
on the majority in the United Nations
under the manipulation and coercion of
the US government continued to use
server China's lawful feet in
denominations I can tell you frankly
that's not only would it be impossible
to improve and to restore sino-american
relations but what is more will have
nothing whatsoever do with the United
Nations yes such a situation should a
Rio
sino-american confrontation once again
will not be a question of a few years
it'll be of a long duration if we don't
know how many years it'll remain that
way until the day college and I believe
it they welcome when united states to
find itself how long able to continue
along this path and gives up this polity
by rapidly the number of nations that
flavor restoring China's seat and the UN
is increasing one more nations now
maintain relations with China may be
that there's a majority already in favor
of feeding China in the UN do you expect
to see is China's seat restored this
year know how that is in the present
session 1965 hey do not epic win in LA
that's not popular although there are
Wow
fifty countries would have recognized us
and established diplomatic relations
with us and the number will perhaps
increase brother the United States will
be able to use various methods to
obstruct the restoration of our
legitimate rights in the United Nations
and prevent the expulsion of the Chiang
kai-shek reconvene a finish
there was certainly no change yet they
played this year in the meantime we have
an urgent new factor involved in sin or
American relations the bomb
judging from reports published abroad
China's bomb was a much more
sophisticated nature than American
experts anticipated now when it would be
possible for you to comment on just what
it is meant in terms of China's
technological and scientific engineering
development so each other
Tiku ended and a jingle de Cler hope
Allah may with a joinha Imaginext will
have come to the conclusion from the
data they collected the technical level
of the atom bomb we exploded is higher
than that of the first nuclear test of
the United States Britain a friend I'm
just like off with you this way the
American experts didn t know more than
you do maybe change opinion perhaps
automata I do over the will say download
my Dharma is greater tension in
Southeast Asia especially in Vietnam
Laos and Cambodia is reaching a critical
stage may I ask under what circumstances
China would render aid to these
countries such as she extended to North
Korea Vega in the situation in South
Vietnam is linked with the entire
Indochina question and it is precisely
on the question of expanding the war in
Indochina to the United States is now
hesitant
it's always anxious to know China's a
titular planet attitude is very clear
that is if the United States should run
rampant in Indochina we will definitely
not sit idly by the United States has
tasted of the Korean War and if you want
to wear the green our boy Indochina it
should know what will happen and what
the result will be therefore the United
States may acquaint itself with our
attitude simply through our published
statements however the US government
often doesn't believe these statements
it always thinks that our public
statements are one thing and what we
actually intend to do is another the
United States is always anxious to get
some inside information thinking that
only then can decide on politics doesn't
understand that's throughout the 50
years since the founding of the People's
Republic of China every word that was
spoken counts we mean what we say unlike
them we don't practice double tech they
say one thing while doing another how's
the socialist state we're responsible to
the Chinese people and responsible to
the people for the whole world
we live up to our word I hope we have
time for one question on Sinnoh Soviet
relation as patsy most direct them would
be since the fall of Cousteau does China
still insist that sorghum you should not
participate in the next afro-asian
conference where other way to India or
Mercer and GND return so with regard to
the forthcoming African Asian conference
we firmly applied by all the agreements
reached at the preparatory meeting for
the second fishing African conference
held last April in Jakarta
at that meeting as in the tandem
conference inanimate II had to be
achieved before agreement on any
question could be reached as for those
questions
puts the majority of the parties before
you did not approve our vow which no
agreement could be reached they were
satisfied the principles of reaching
agreement through anonymity and seeking
common ground while retaining
differences are precisely the pantone
spirit commonly acknowledged of Asia and
African countries
these principles were once again here to
educause up territory meeting well
that's very clear I have 100 other
questions but I think I will have
consumed all the time you've generously
allotted make and I want to thank you
very much for very enlightening
interview yeah
we're thank you good good bye well in
this